well the ego can't reflect upon itself
unless it has a mirror against which to
read itself and that mirror would be the
mythological schedule that lets it know
where it is
it's a mirror with a schedule on it
a patterned mirror and the ego sees
itself
in that reflex and knows where it is on
this on the scoreboard
just for example a person who at the age
of 40 is wondering whether
he's going to be punished by mother
hasn't hasn't uh
hasn't moved on and a person at the age
of
80 who's wondering how's my god score he
hasn't moved on either
i mean just in raw gross way this is
uh this is the problem this lets you
know where you are
and it knows what the patterns have been
of life
through centuries in that position that
you now
are entering our holding he should see
himself the 40 year old now should see
himself
as a free willing independent
self-responsible human being
and he should have certain noble heart
powers
that have been called to his attention
and then to which he has been invited to
give himself
that will enable him to act in terms of
nobility
not in obedience you know but out of
himself
and uh the older person must know i'm
now
not now participating in the achievement
of life
i have achieved it and i'm looking back
and
i can tell you there's a wonderful
moment that comes when you realize
i'm not striving for anything
and what i'm doing now is not a means to
achieving something later
youth has always to think that way every
decision a young
person makes is a commitment to a life
course and if you make a bad decision of
that angle by the time you get out there
you're far off course
but after a certain age there's no
future
and suddenly the present becomes rich
it becomes that thing in itself which
you're now experiencing and if you've
been prepared a little bit for that
you're ready if you don't know i've had
the experience of lecturing to
old age groups you know and myself
actually in old age
i'm i'll be
79 next month
i can tell you there came a gradual
realization boy this
is it i'm in that place and
every experience is of value in and for
itself without any reference to anything
that might happen
i've i've mentioned this to older groups
and people come up to me afterward and
say
we didn't realize
it's beautiful and those figures that
you see i can think of a couple of
renaissance pictures
of an old man or an old woman looking at
a just born
child these are the two eternities
the youth the the lovely young thing
and the old one who's not in history
anymore but in between
is history you're participating in a
historically conditioned culture
and part of the role of myth is to
relate that historical conditioning to
what
the old man and the child present across
the ages of life